i've been getting a lot of comments from
men on my pro-choice videos saying that
they're totally fine with a woman's
right to terminate if her health is at
risk or her body is in jeopardy but i
don't think that these misogynists
realize okay take a pause real quick
you'll often hear this well i oppose
abortion except for cases of rape incest
or a risk to the life of the mother
now the logic here doesn't make a lot of
sense obviously rape is a heinous crime
it's one of the most heinous crimes
there is incest too but if the logic of
abortion is
the babe either the baby's a baby or the
baby is not a baby then the method of
conception doesn't really matter to the
rights of the baby obviously there can
be heinous crimes involved but we're
still talking about is the baby a baby
or is the baby not a baby and is it okay
to kill babies
then when you get to the question of the
risk to the life of the mother this
basically does not exist there is no
complication or disease or ailment for
which the cure is an abortion